this is the second video in a new series
that I'm creating for people who are
independent learners those who want to
engage in self-directed study of
philosophy but have some worries or
concerns or questions about where to
begin and who to begin with and how to
do it this video focuses directly on
Aristotle and touches a little bit on
the Aristotelian tradition that
continues all the way to the present but
focuses mostly on how you can do
productive study of Aristotle's texts
Aristotle is a very important thinker in
the history of philosophy there's very
good reasons for this which we'll talk
about in just a bit and on a personal
note I'll mention that although I'm not
a strict Aristotelian and I find many of
his insights and approaches and
sometimes even doctrines or systematic
ways of viewing things to be
extraordinarily helpful not just in
terms of philosophy as a theoretical
enterprise but as a practical enterprise
as well
I've been studying Aristotle and
teaching him for more than two decades
when it comes to the studying the
teaching I've been teaching him for two
decades my very first class that I
taught included a good bit of his nickim
Achaean ethics and a little bit of his
politics so he's somebody who I know and
appreciate quite a lot and I'm hoping
that I can get that across to you and
help you as an independent learner as
somebody engaged in self-directed study
to be able to make some progress in
studying this great thinkers texts and
ideas
it's a legitimate and worthwhile
I think it's certainly one that you
ought to ask yourself why should I study
Aristotle in the first place this is a
question you can ask of anybody who
you're gonna devote time and thought and
energy to so in Aristotle's case there's
going to be a lot of good answers to
this but let's let's deepen the question
you've only got so much time you've only
got so much energy you've only got so
much capacity to store things in your
mind and to learn new things why should
you focus on this philosopher from you
know ancient Athens years and years two
millennia ago why should you focus on
him instead of focusing on somebody more
contemporary well it's not to say that
you can't focus on anybody who is more
contemporary but you really don't want
to pass up Aristotle he's somebody who's
absolutely important to learn and to
engage with any philosophy program that
you would attend if it's worth anything
we'll have you studying some of
Aristotle's texts and engaging his
thought to some degree one reason why
you want to study Aristotle in the first
place is that he is providing a
philosophical approach of a lot of
explanatory power and major significance
it's worth remembering that he was
Plato's best student and when he of
course didn't get to become the Skull
arc the leader of the Platonic school
after going back off and doing some
other things he returned to Athens to
found his own school the Lyceum which
became the Peripatetic school you see it
referred to that way and this has been
viewed not only as one of the very
important philosophical schools of the
ancient world but it played a major role
in medieval philosophy it continued on
through modern philosophy and there are
neo Aristotelian in the present so by
studying Aristotle you're prepping
yourself for you know understanding a
lot more than just Aristotle himself he
also as somebody who's early in the the
you know
beginnings of philosophy as a discipline
in fact he's one of the people who
separates out all these different sub
disciplines as areas of study in a
systematic way he sets some central
problems and issues and even vocabulary
in ancient Greek of course translated
into all sorts of other languages so he
sets those things for us and it's
worthwhile studying his his texts and
his thoughts so that you can familiarize
yourself with those and and then when
you encounter them and other thinkers
you know what you're running into
he's also exercised an incredible amount
of influence on other philosophers down
to the present time there isn't a period
of history within the the West where he
didn't have some influence you could say
well what about the Middle Ages before
they rediscovered Aristotle they still
had some Aristotle they had the
categories and on interpretation and
they knew about Aristotle's doctrines
from people like Seneca and Cicero and
so you know and boëthius
so there was some discussion of him even
when they didn't have all of the texts
in hand but in the Islamic world in the
Byzantine world they had Aristotle
throughout all of that time and you know
you could say well what about the modern
period where we rejected Aristotle
didn't Galileo say that you know we
could get rid of all this silly
Aristotelian physics well true and there
were a lot of people who rejected you
know the Scholastic's and Aristotle but
when you're rejecting something that is
being influenced by it right it's it's
your your enemy it's your rival and
Aristotle like many other philosophical
figures and movements has had his rises
and falls right now this is a time in
the 21st century where there's a very
strong neo Aristotelian movement going
that's been strong for for quite some
time never Aristotle never really went
out of favor in some circles anyway but
you know the point is
his influence extends throughout the
entire history of philosophy so he's
worth studying for that reason as well
another important reason to study
Aristotle is it really has to do more
with your own development what you're
going to encounter in reading through
his text is a systematic treatment of
areas or objects of knowledge he treats
things in what he views as a scientific
or disciplinary way and so whether you
agree with him or disagree with him it's
well worth knowing what he has to say
and where he draws the divisions between
the different disciplines it's also
incredibly good exercise for your own
mind just like with reading Plato's
dialogues or reading later philosophers
by trying to puzzle out what Aristotle
is saying and correlate the things that
he says in one part to another part you
are exercising your mind whether you
agree with Aristotle or disagree with
them
you will get some benefit from studying
him in this respect so those are all
good reasons for studying this great
Greek thinker
when you're going to engage in
self-directed study there's a set of
very practical questions that you're
going to ask about the texts which text
you ought to have which translations
which additions and how you ought to be
studying them so let's start by talking
about additions and translations first
so there's good news and there's bad
news the good news is there's lots and
lots and lots of different translations
of aristotelian works out there some of
them have been translated into English
dozens of times by different people some
perhaps little more obscure texts less
than that and you can pick and choose
between them there is no one single
absolutely best translation as a matter
of fact if you don't have Greek I
suggest that you you know if you want to
study a particular text you consult
different translations you know you can
compare and contrast how they how the
translators choose to to articulate what
it is that he's saying at different
points some good translations will have
notes you know that that will say well
this is the Greek term and here's what
it means they may have a glossary in the
back and and that's up to you to look
around to find those sorts of things the
other bit of good news is that quite a
few of these translations are actually
available online because many of the
older translations are public domain
texts early in the the you know
beginnings of the internet there were
quite a few people who thought let's put
Aristotle's texts online for people as a
resource and so you can find MIT and the
Perseus project and all sorts of other
really great websites doing that so all
you got to do is put it into Google you
know Aristotle nikka McKay and ethics
and you'll find it online it may not be
the most current translation but current
isn't always necessarily the best there
is no one-size-fits-all answer about
translations really depends on you the
reader so I would encourage you to check
out different ones and you don't have to
buy them necessarily go online take a
look at them go to used bookstores you
can pick up copies very cheap
especially in university towns go to
your local library they're bound to have
some text by Aristotle that you can
check out and read now you know do you
need to have a big book that includes
all of Aristotle's stuff I don't think
that you you necessarily do there are a
few anthologies that include all or many
of his texts certainly the ones that
you'd want to read the most and I'll
mention just three of them and I'll put
links to them below one is the complete
works of Aristotle put out by Oxford
University Press
in two volumes two big thick volumes
that's if you really really want to have
everything that we have by Aristotle as
a matter of fact I should mention we
don't actually have all of Aristotle's
texts many of them were lost in
antiquity as often the case for ancient
literature but we have a lot and so you
know if you want to buy that you
certainly could it's not going to hurt
you to do that the translations are by
different people
then there's the basic works of
Aristotle that's a big thick volume as
well that's by the modern library
classics and then Hackett who I think
some of you may have you know seen
before I always recommend Hackett
translations in part because they're
very cheap very affordable they have an
introductory readings now the flaw with
that one is that it doesn't include
entire works it includes selections from
works but if you want to you know sort
of introductory I want to get to know
Aristotle a bit that that's quite good
Aristotle's works you're also gonna find
anthologized in so many other philosophy
textbooks anthologies guidebooks
whatever it is that you're looking at
you'll find you know the entire knick of
McKay ethics in book after book after
book or the entire politics or perhaps
even the entire metaphysics in some of
them so it's not as if it's hard to get
your hands on Aristotle eerie in the
opposite situation then people were say
in the Middle Ages the question is well
which which Edition do you need to have
and there's no
you know one single right answer as a
reader take a look at it and understand
of course that Aristotle is going to be
difficult and see if you're able to make
sense of it if if you need a very modern
translation a very up-to-date
translation get that for yourself if you
can deal with these somewhat you know
Oxford II old-fashioned language of
earlier translations by all means go
with that and you'll be perfectly fine
there is a big question however about
where to start and so we're going to
look at that next
once you've supplied yourself with
perhaps a beginner's library or an
anthology of aristotelian text the next
question that comes up is well where
should I start which book should I read
first what's the introductory book to
Aristotle and unfortunately there's a
little bit of bad news
there is no introductory book to
Aristotle there is a sort of prescribed
traditional way of going at Aristotle's
works but it's not really that helpful
to do that
and this prescribed way is to begin with
what we call the organon which is the
logical works and they usually begin
first time readers with a book called
the category so that's when I first
started reading eros tall that's what I
got and you know I've actually this
little bit of a digression I shot a
bunch of core concept videos and I'm
putting together an online course with
learners on the categories because so
many people get prescribed this and
they're like what in the hell is this I
have no idea what he's talking about or
what any of this is supposed to mean
it's not really a beginner level book as
a matter of fact there is no beginner
level book in Aristotle there's no
introduction to the system by Aristotle
there is no you know prolegomena or
anything like that instead what you get
is straight out Aristotle doing his
thing so the categories and then the
other logical works which would include
everything from you know on
interpretation and the prior posterior
analytics all the way down into
sophistical refutations all the way down
into the topics those are what a lot of
people start with but I think that if
you do that unless you really really
like syllogisms and epistemology you're
probably going to get a little bit
turned off and probably quite confused
another thing that some people sometimes
do is try to start with the metaphysics
bad idea not the work to start with you
know there's you could do that but
you're gonna be so lost in going into it
I tend to think that really the best
book to to begin with and and it's still
not a
to begin with is the nikah mccain ethics
and that's what i start students on it's
a little bit easier to sort of wrap your
head around it it is still difficult and
confusing in parts for reasons that
we'll talk about but it's a nice dive
into to Aristotle's method and the key
ideas and and approaches that that he's
going to make germane so you know
there's a couple different ways you can
go you could start with this traditional
thing of do the organ on first you could
also some people try to initiate people
by having them read the de anima or on
the soul that's kind of a tough work as
well then there's there's the approach
of beginning with the nick of mckay and
ethics and going through what we call
the ethical political works the nick of
mccain ethics and the adamian ethics are
two different books that actually
overlap to some degree and discuss some
of the same topics along with them is
the politics which is you know
explicitly said to follow from book ten
of the nikah mckay and ethics you're
ready to go into the politics now and
there's a few other works that fit into
that spectrum of ethical political works
the rhetoric is also very important the
poetics which unfortunately we only have
book one of and then I would say certain
parts of the topics particularly book
three of the the topics some some other
stuff in there as well you know here's
the thing though when you're reading
Aristotle really you could pick any book
to start with and you're gonna have the
same experience which is reading some of
it and being like what is going on here
I'm not understanding three-quarters of
what I'm encountering I mean if you do
think you're understanding
three-quarters of what you're
encountering and you're going at it cold
you're mistaken so you're gonna have
that experience and be like oh man I
feel like I'm out of my depth here
that's fine that's that's normal for
reading Aristotle you're gonna read that
and and you know you're gonna come back
to it later on and you're gonna get more
each time that you read you're gonna get
more when you read across the corpus
when you read one book and then read
another book then read another book and
start making connections with them and
not just books from say the ethical
political works and them illogical works
or maybe the physical works you know the
biology stuff you're gonna see
connections between them and your
reading is gonna get richer and richer
so in some respects you know it's it's
not that important where you begin but I
would say you know if you had to pick
just one book to start with I would say
the nikah McKay and ethics but if you
want to start with the categories go on
ahead if you want to start with the
metaphysics and be very confused go on
ahead if you want to start with one of
the physical works parts of animals or
you know any you know on the heavens you
can do that if you want to but you won't
probably get as much out of it so you
know you're you are gonna have to read
and reread don't worry about getting
everything out of any one single reading
especially at the beginning you're gonna
find it difficult another thing I do
want to point out at the start is that
when you read a text and then you read
another related text the translations
may not translate the Greek terms
exactly the same way so that you know
something that's being discussed in the
nikah McKay and ethics may not have
exactly the same wording as what's being
discussed in the politics or in the
topics or in on the soul and you have to
do a bit of philosophical detective work
sometimes this is where having a
glossary that has the Greek terms could
be quite useful for you so that you can
figure out you know he's talking about
the same thing
at this point another thing to keep in
mind as well I would say is don't assume
and this goes for any philosophical
reading that terms that you're
encountering in English mean exactly the
same thing as they do in our normal
everyday speaking about things or
correspond directly to dictionary
definitions philosophical vocabulary is
a bit different and so you need to be
attuned to that so that you don't
confuse yourself too much in that way
the other thing that I do want to point
out is
about about his text is that the key
ideas are not always going to get their
full treatment they're not going to get
every single thing discussing them just
in this text so for example on the sole
is not the only place where Aristotle
discusses the soul and its parts and
activities and you know things like
perception and desire and thinking
there's discussions of this in all sorts
of other works as well and so the more
that you're reading the more you're
going to start seeing the connections
and the more you're going to start
seeing the same topics being discussed
in different works and the more you'll
be able to put them together into some
sort of coherent picture so that's a lot
of stuff to talk about in how to start
but I think that could be useful for a
self-directed learner especially if
they're approaching Aristotle for the
first time
I do also have some useful advice for
you that stems directly from the genre
and approach and structure of
Aristotelian text themselves and and
this is based on you know reading and
rereading and rereading and also from
from teaching where I see students
running into problems so there's a
number of different things that that
fall into this and hopefully these these
tips will be helpful for you the first
thing that I do want to say is that when
you're reading Aristotle try not to
bring too many you know assumptions and
structures and demands from the outside
to superimpose upon his works you really
need to learn from Aristotle himself
reading his works or you know somebody
else who can guide you through that how
the works are structured and how the
different divisions or disciplinary
areas are going to be distinguished from
each other and and what they require so
you know logical works are gonna read a
little bit differently than the physical
works are going to read a little bit
differently than the ethical political
works and and so on so Aristotle himself
will give you clues about that and
sometimes he'll actually give you
outright doctrines he'll say for example
that ethical topics are not the same
thing as physical topics or that you
know looking at the soul the physical
philosopher or you like somebody doing
medicine is going to look at things in a
different light than will the
dialectical philosopher the psychologist
who's interested in in how the soul
works and how the emotions function so
that's one important thing another thing
that's really closely connected with
this is don't expect to get a completely
systematic comprehensive discussion of
most topics from Aristotle when he
presents things in his philosophical
tree
which many people think are actually
lecture notes and the verdict is kind of
out that whether that's that's really
the case or not he'll often tell you I'm
going to give you the outlines of things
you have to fill them in and so he'll
give you examples he'll say this is
connected to this but he doesn't flesh
everything out all the time this is
particularly the case in those ethical
political works like the Nicomachean
ethics the politics the rhetoric he says
I'm giving you the structure you have to
actually fill it up with content I'll
give you a few examples to help you
along the way but it's up to you the
reader and so when you're reading that
sort of thing
you do want to try to think about how
would I apply this how would this
actually work out and when you run into
something where there isn't necessarily
an answer where it seems like he's just
stopped here that's going to be the way
it is it's under determined and so you
can't expect the same sort of
comprehensiveness from Aristotle as you
might from a later philosopher another
thing that's really important to keep in
mind for many of Aristotle's works is
that they are what he calls dialectical
at least in parts so what does this mean
this is something he talks about in the
topic so if you want to understand
Aristotelian dialectics then you want to
read that work the topics but I'm going
to give you a sort of a thumbnail sketch
and you'll see this playing itself out
in so many of his works particularly in
the introductory material but also going
from book to book to book that is
chapter to chapter to chapter in in
modern parlance right he'll begin by
saying okay here's a topic what does
what does everyone else have to say
about this what are some of the problems
what are some of the issues that they
bring up and what do people think about
this and he'll talk about what other
philosophers before him had to say he'll
talk about other people who are
intellectuals in some way like
playwrights or you know sometimes
politicians or other people who are who
are famous those are
oftentimes the wise or the you know the
illustrious or however you want to talk
about them and then he'll also talk
about what what most people or many
people think about a particular topic as
well and now why is he doing that well
you know he doesn't think that you have
to reinvent the wheel when you're doing
philosophy as a matter of fact instead
of just trying to like go off by
yourself and clear your head and then
think about something you know with your
own original thoughts you're probably
actually better off seeing what other
intelligent people people who are able
to function well had to say about it so
those are what we call and Doakes up
those get translated as like starting
points or opinions and he generally
begins by looking at those but that
doesn't mean that he accepts all of them
on you know face value instead he he
looks at them critically critically
means making judgments correct ace is
actually a judge like a judge of a
poetry contest right or a judge in a
trial and he says this part over here
this is good we're gonna keep that but
it's got to be understood a little bit
different way this other stuff we're
gonna get rid of that and that's the way
he begins his systematic works you're
gonna see this in the nick of McCain
ethics you're gonna see this in book one
of the metaphysics you're gonna see this
an on the soul there's usually going to
be some dialectical discussion and then
he tries to go further with that and
make it more scientific not in the way
of like scientific method the way you
think about today that you got
introduced to an elementary or middle
school with hypotheses and all that sort
of stuff but scientific in the sense of
a systematic body of knowledge that is
developed out of these these sorts of
things so the dialectical approach is
particularly important another thing
that you want to be forewarned about you
are gonna see a lot of what seem to be
complete digressions on Aristotle's part
where he says you know we're going to
talk about this and then he veers off
into a sub discussion and he sticks with
that for quite a while for example in
the nick of mccain ethics in book 1 he's
talked
about happiness and the function of
human beings and you know those sorts of
topics he veers off into an interesting
discussion that bears upon the happiness
of the dead and whether the fortunes of
their descendants have anything to do
with that which seems to be you know
completely irrelevant doesn't it or in
politics book one he's got all these
sort of side conversations going on one
about you know slavery one about you
know the nature of wealth and how that
works how much you need for a household
all of these actually do fit in
somewhere and here's the thing to keep
in mind sooner or later
Aristotle comes back to the main point
if you read on further you're gonna see
him saying alright let's return back to
this topic why did he go off on these
digressions well you know if you're
looking at an issue or a phenomena or
something that's complex particularly
things that are you know have a
metaphysical depth to them or our
complex like human beings are and our
social interactions you got to look at
it from different sides so that is what
he's doing is saying let's look at this
phenomenon from this side now let's look
at it from this side now let's look at
it from this side and all of these sort
of circlings around you could understand
them sort of like spiraling in getting
closer and closer to what it is that he
wants us to to understand and to know so
be forewarned that's gonna happen a lot
he's gonna pick up the same issue the
same question the same problem and look
at it in different ways trying to get
you the reader to understand it in its
fullness another thing that you want to
keep in mind Aristotle is well known for
being one of the early contributors to
the discipline of logic and as a matter
of fact I mentioned the organ on if you
read his logical works you're gonna see
a lot of what we nowadays call logic and
a lot of epistemology and sort of you
know methods of inquiry in there he
doesn't always follow that as a matter
of fact in the ethical political works
he rarely sets things up in terms of
explicit arguments and syllogisms there
are a lot of people who want to try to
read that in that's usually a mistake as
a matter of fact even great thinkers
like Thomas Aquinas in their commentary
on on Aristotle will often fall into
this trap of thinking that a syllogism
is always this three-part argument with
a major premise minor premise conclusion
the way that Aristotle uses Sulu geese
most right or Sula geese Thayne which
are the Greek words that we get
syllogism from it's a little bit broader
than that you know anger for example he
says in nikka mckay and ethics book
seven cyllage eise's that doesn't mean
that anger actually like it's on a track
board and sets out a three-part argument
it's more complex than that and so you
know I mentioned don't try to read too
many things in from the outside and
impose them on Aristotle that's what we
call instead of exegesis pulling things
out of the text ace of Jesus reading
things into the text you also don't want
to do that with this syllogistic
approach to things except maybe in some
of the works where it actually does show
up there are some key ideas that you're
going to see recurring running
throughout Aristotle's work I'm not
going to try to summarize all of them at
this point but I'll put a few of them up
there on your horizon
so you're gonna see him talking about
causes idea in in Greek those are the
explanations for why something is the
way it is why something exists why it's
in the condition that it is and he
distinguishes a number of different
types of causes that are in his view not
reducible to each other so that's one
important thing he also talks about the
categories the categories of being the
things that can be predicated the things
that can be said of something else and
so that's something that you want to be
attentive to as well another key idea is
that of the mean or middle this is
really important in his ethics but it
shows up also in the rhetoric and in the
the poetics to a little extent and also
in the politics some discussions of that
this is the mess oh that's something
that's in between this is absolutely
central to Aristotle's virtue ethics as
he articulates it in his ethics the
distinction between possibility and
actuality also quite important the
notion of there being ends hell you know
a Telos to something a good or purpose
to that that's one of the four causes
but that also plays a major role and and
you can have these complex and telly
keys these systems where there there's
this you know relation you know sort of
a hierarchical set up where the the
thing that's you know the the end is
really a means to something else and
this is very important for a wrister
Tilian reasoning he's also very
interested in the relationship between
parts and wholes as well and you're
gonna notice one other thing and this is
something I'll end on you can really
take to the bank with you as we say
Aristotle will make lots of distinctions
now that's something that philosophy is
particularly good at where does he make
distinctions does he make distinctions
just for the sake of making them no very
rarely does he do that so whenever you
see him saying well this can be
understood in this way or this way or
this way there's something there that
you shouldn't discount
he makes distinctions when we get to a
term that is ambiguous where it's got
multiple meanings for example
nikka mckay and ethics book five justice
Aristotle says this is a term that
people get all you know up in a
disagreement about the again all
bollixed up why because they don't
realize they're not talking about
exactly the same thing this is a term
that means multiple things that are
connected with each other but aren't
exactly the same so he'll make
distinctions and it's very important to
respect the distinctions that he makes
maybe we want to make additional
distinctions beyond them you know for
example his distinction between three
different main types of friendship maybe
he didn't go far enough with that right
but we begin with what he's what he lays
out for us and then we can go further
with these distinctions as indeed many
of the commentators do so that's some
advice for you about format genre
structure of Aristotle's works hopefully
that will be helpful to you to keep in
mind as you're reading his stuff
given how incredibly influential
Aristotle has been throughout the
centuries and the fact that there are
plenty of neo Aristotelian 's out there
today I thought that it might be good to
talk about you know tradition and
commentaries and what this neo
Aristotelian term means and whether you
have to be concerned with that as you're
beginning your studies of Aristotle and
the simple answer is no you don't you
can actually study Aristotle on his own
without having to bring in secondary
sources without having to look at
commentaries or interpretations of his
texts you don't have to bother with that
necessarily although there's nothing to
say that you can't also do that and I
think it's good to know for you know if
you're gonna continue to study Aristotle
where other people who are interested in
Aristotle are coming from so let's talk
about first the ancient and medieval and
even some of the early modern
commentaries on Aristotle there is this
long tradition of people who are either
Aristotelian themselves they identify as
Aristotelian x' and they use his his
methodology and his key ideas or they're
not Aristotelian but they're in some way
considering his stuff people who do
commentaries on his his works now a
commentary is where you take a text and
you say here's what the the says in the
text and here's the things that I have
to say in addition to that or here's
where it seems confusing here's what I
think
Aristotle means and there's a long
commentary tradition of Aristotelian x'
commenting on Aristotle's texts going
through them the the the ancient period
all the way into the Middle Ages so I'll
just mention a few people who would fit
into that one would be you know say
somebody like Alexander of Aphrodisias
right we have quite a few of his texts
where he's comment
on Aristotle sometimes he is because
he's got a vantage point that Aristotle
didn't have he's engaging with other
philosophical schools he's saying the
Stoics say this but here's an
Aristotelian response to that because
Aristotle didn't didn't know the Stoics
they didn't exist at his time you know
we could fast forward a number of years
to somebody like for example Thomas
Aquinas or many of the other medievals
Thomas wrote commentaries on quite a few
of Aristotle's texts
he also wrote commentaries on another
commentator Boethius who himself did a
commentary Buie theists at one point
before he died unfortunately had the
idea of translating all of Plato's texts
and all of Aristotle's texts from Greek
into Latin now unfortunately he died
before he could do more than just a
handful of Aristotle's tax categories
and on interpretation but those are
commentaries and so you know Thomas
Aquinas knows these commentaries and he
you know mentions them himself so
there's this long tradition of engaging
with other commentators again do you
yourself have to engage with this in
order to understand Aristotle no and as
a matter of fact at the beginning stages
I would say to stay out of that sort of
thing altogether figure out you know at
least the the rudiments of Aristotle's
position before you start bringing in
other voices because they might sway you
a little bit too much we can also talk
about more modern commentary and this
comes in the form of you know books and
academic articles or you know it could
also be a bit more informal like the
videos that you see taking classes
handouts things like that these are all
attempts to try to make sense out of
what Aristotle is saying and they can be
at a very very high academic level or
they can be for beginners the one thing
that I would say to watch out for is
anybody who claims to have a system for
totally understanding Aristotle the
texts that we have don't comprise a
system there's many places where
as I mentioned Aristotle is rather
underdetermined so anybody who claims to
like have given you the the key to
unlock all of Aristotle's stuff and
categorize everything you should be
suspicious of that because they're
usually going to be wrong there's a lot
of people who in the 20th century were
quite enthusiastic about Aristotle and
who provided interpretations of
Aristotle but we look at and we're like
yeah I don't really think that going
back to Aristotle's text this is a
faithful reinterpretation of Aristotle
you always have to ask you know is there
a back and forth between the text not
that people who bring something else to
it and are also quite brilliant might
not have something very interesting to
contribute but you know you always want
to make sure that the thinker is front
and center not so in Zoe's
interpretation of the thinker so you
know you you don't want to take on the
sort of modern equivalents of Thomas
Aquinas Thomas is taking Aristotle and
reading him in a certain way you know in
some respects very respectful but in
other respects pasting and superimposing
a lot of things on Aristotle reading
things in there that aren't necessarily
there and so you know it's quite all
right to use modern you know articles or
you know resources books commentaries on
Aristotle just make sure that when
you're doing that you're not
substituting a secondary text for the
primary texts of Aristotle himself and
you're not making Aristotle say more
than he's actually saying in his in his
works now I mentioned that there are neo
Aristotelian Zout there you might say
well what's the difference between them
and Aristotelians so neo Aristotelian z'
is the word that we use for people who
are using Aristotle there they're
beginning from Aristotle no they're
explicitly and deliberately saying we
got to add this stuff in we have to
reinterpret this I understand that this
is not what Aristotle said
but we're going to include something
else so for example I was at a
conference a few years back and there
was a really great paper being put out
about Aristotle and water ethics and it
was it was saying this is a neo wrist
Italian take Aristotle thought that the
universe was eternal and that you know
resources were more or less you know not
necessarily renewable but inexhaustible
and he didn't have the conception of the
environment that we have but we do have
this this conception of a essentially
finite and and rouen abaut environment
that we need to take care of so we're
beginning from these starting points and
then we're using Aristotle to talk about
this sort of thing that's what it means
to be a neo Aristotelian you know a lot
of the the the revival of virtue ethics
in the 20th century in the
anglo-american world because it never
actually went out of favor and in France
and Germany and other places like that a
lot of that is what we would call neo
wrists Italian and some of it is not
that closely connected with Aristotle's
text and some of it is very closely
connected with it there's also people
out there who are neo Aristotelian in a
much more substantive way you could
think for example of Alistair McIntyre
and his you know project of tradition
constituted inquiry running from after
virtue all the way you know through the
the works you know whose justice which
rationality all the way up to dependent
rational animals and continuing on as
well that's Aristotelian and that's
there's many people who've been
following him and using his work and
expanding beyond it as well so we can
talk about revolutionary aristotelianism
all of that is part of this great great
tradition of appropriating and
reinterpreting Aristotle again do you
need to read that in order to understand
Aristotle do you need their for example
to read Alistair McIntyre's after virtue
you don't you don't need to read
commentaries you don't need to read
somebody's latest work about Aristotle
you can go to
the texts themselves but after you've
been doing that for a while you might
want to become part of that larger
conversation and so you'll start looking
around for that and you know there is no
like recipe or list of what the best
Aristotelian source texts are you know
for for literature on him or about him
but you'll sort of sort that out as you
go along so that's all I really need to
say about about that issue
there are a few other problems and
issues that we really do need to address
in part because if we don't they're
likely to become a stumbling block and
and lead many people who would otherwise
put the time in and the effort to
understand Aristotle to you know discard
that that process so what I have in mind
are ways in which Aristotle's texts
themselves and some of the assumptions
and some of the outright declarations
that he might make are you know they're
surpassed they're outmoded they've been
revealed as fundamentally problematic or
or sometimes just completely wrong and
so we could start by talking about his
physics and his biology as well I mean
Aristotle is doing good science for his
time but you know science has passed him
up I you know there are some people out
there that are trying to do some things
with Aristotelian physics or
understandings of you know biology in
terms of entelechy or you know
discussions of Aristotelian ism and in
mathematics but most of those are what
we call non starters it's it's probably
not worth trying to resuscitate an
Aristotelian point of view at least in
that respect and his logic has not been
discarded as such I mean if you take a
logic course and it's worth anything you
will study some Aristotelian logic and
that's fun and that's usable for some
things but you know modern logic has
indeed gone beyond there's a matter of
fact the Stoics already went beyond the
Aristotelian logic and contributed some
some new things but it's still worth
studying it's just Aristotle's logic
doesn't cover everything that it would
need to when we move on to matters of
the ethical and political works we see
that Aristotle's point of view is you
know to a large extent conditioned by
the culture of his time he says a lot of
boneheaded things about women about
people who are
in a slave or subservient position about
working people in general about
everybody who's not a Greek the people
that he calls barbarians and when you
see these sorts of things you you have a
couple different choices you could ask
you could you know ask yourself what is
he really getting at here or you could
like say oh this is all this is awful
you know these are not acceptable things
to be saying let's throw the book away
or you could say I wonder if in
Aristotle's texts there are some
resources for rethinking this or you
could say if Aristotle were here today
and he'd say went into a classroom where
you know many of the classes I teach are
more women than men and he heard them
conversing would he really still say the
same kind of things that he said you
know going from the culture of his own
time when he revised the things that he
had to say and so I think that that
that's quite important by the way I'll
mention just one other thing
many of the Aristotelian scholars of the
20th century who I cite in my own
research and who I have derived a lot of
of you know benefit from in reading are
in fact women Julia Anna's Giselle
Giselle Ostreicher you know we could go
down the list of you know really
important I think there's Amelie Rorty
you know so clearly they don't think
that you should just throw Aristotle
away because he said stupid things about
women that he would probably revise in
the present so that that's something
important to keep in mind and you can
work out your own position on that if
you want to there's one other thing as
well that I think is worth bringing up
if you get into Aristotelian scholarship
you will sometimes see them discussing
which text came before which other text
it's a similar problem to what goes on
with plato's tax it's what we call the
genetic ordering right where did this
text come into being in relation to
others and there are some that we can be
that you know this text had to come
before this text because you know the
earlier text is being mentioned in the
later text we can be confident although
maybe you know he went back and rewrote
that when it comes down to it we really
don't know many of these theories about
the ordering of the Aristotelian text
and when exactly they were written
they're pretty speculative and they
don't really have much important to say
about how you ought to be reading
Aristotle it was a very popular thing to
do in German scholarship in the 19th and
early 20th century to be engaging in
this this sort of analysis but it didn't
contribute an awful lot of illumination
to understanding Aristotle in his own
right so I don't think that you need to
be particularly worried about it
so what I've brought up in this this
section are concerns that you might have
in part because other people seem to be
concerned about them and I'm saying to
you if you're going to study Aristotle
as somebody who wants to you know
immerse themselves in the history of
philosophy learn some important thinkers
and texts along the way engage in this
process of self-directed study don't let
those things become obstacles to you
don't let them become stumbling blocks
or scandals you know I'm going to say
the same thing just keep going back to
the Aristotelian text that will be
enough work for you already
so I've got a few final thoughts for
first of all if you are studying
Aristotle on your own doing
self-directed study that's really great
I congratulate you I'll congratulate you
more after you've read your way through
some Aristotelians texts but I think
it's a wonderful thing for you to be
doing is such an important philosopher
and it's going to be a good bit of work
for you the second thing I'll say is I
think you can tell by this point that
Aristotle is somebody I'm quite
passionate about I've been teaching him
for 20 years and studying him for even
longer I didn't appreciate him at the
beginning as a matter of fact I didn't
like him until I started studying him in
Greek and then so many things opened up
for me but a lot of other people read
him or encounter him in my classes and
they're like this is really wonderful
great stuff and and I'm always happy to
see people turned on by Aristotle the
third thing that I'll say is like most
philosophers you know you can get a long
way by studying Aristotle but don't
expect him to have an answer to
everything that's that's asking too much
of somebody who is you know removed from
us by two millennia and a lot of culture
and a number of different assumptions
but it does provide us with a really
powerful way of approaching things and
and you're gonna find so much cool
useful stuff in his text that's probably
a great place to end this so if you've
watched your way through this whole
video I hope you get cracking on reading
Aristotle's text just keep working at it
and you will find it quite rewarding
you